[Music]
chickens are the most populous bird on
the planet there are 23 billion of them
at any given time that's ten times more
than any other bird it's an astonishing
achievement for a bird that originated
as a small wild jungle bird in Southeast
Asia it's by far the fastest growing
meat product but pound for pound the
price of chicken has fallen sharply how
has this happened this farm is at the
forefront of a technology revolution
that has drastically changed chicken
farming it's run by David speller who's
pioneered the use of CCTV and co2
monitors in chicken sheds along with his
own farm he works as a consultant
overseeing the raising of around 3
million chickens in the UK you can't get
away from the scale yet there are 45,000
birds in this barn managed by one
computer two men will run 200,000 birds
for me chickens were first domesticated
over 8,000 years ago but it wasn't until
the 1940s that major efforts were made
to create a super breed the chicken of
tomorrow competition in America would
change chickens forever
the aim of that competition was to try
and encourage the development of a
fast-growing chicken that could provide
a larger amount of protein at an
affordable cost
the success of the contest proves
conclusively that it is possible to
breed chickens with superior meat type
characteristics today the lifecycle of
broilers chickens that are bred purely
for their meat is entirely preordained
they grow faster and bigger than ever
before and they can only live supported
by human technology modern
industrialized farming requires the use
of artificial light artificial
temperature the whole life of these
birds is controlled
chickens have changed so quickly they
are now four times the size they were in
the 1950s ninety thousand chicks at a
time get delivered it's our job to
nurture them and farm them up to a bird
that's then ready to go back to
processing that starts around day 34 the
biggest bird for us off of this farmer
around 39 days of age then we have a
really frantic 7 to 10 days to clean
everywhere to get it all nice and warm
and fresh ready for the next batch of
chicks we do that seven and a half eight
times a year this efficiency is passed
on to the consumer it's good value
I don't like referring to it as cheap
these are not cheap these are animals
they have a worth but it is great value
it is uniform it's healthy for you and
consumers love it the reality of farming
any animal for meat is you take it to
its optimal place and then you take it
to turn it for human consumption
please birds 38:39 days is as far as we
want to take them for the product that
we want to buy a barnyard chicken can
live up to 10 years showing the huge
evolutionary change the broilers have
undergone but selective breeding and a
global scale comes at a cost if the
chickens live beyond their planned life
they develop huge medical problems these
birds can't then sustain that rapid
weight growth beyond the point at which
they normally slaughtered because their
bodies can't cope with it and it also
puts huge amounts of pressure on
as well and there are concerns the
chicken industry is relying on an
increasingly small gene pool pretty
chicks yes sir
alike as two peas in a pod if all of
these chickens have the same genetics
they're all fed the same food they're
actually very vulnerable to diseases
that come in because they're all
identical so if one bird is affected all
the birds would be affected keeping
chickens in battery cages was banned in
the EU in 2012 but some people want to
create better lives for broiler chickens
free-range birds have more access to
open air runs while organic chickens are
typically free from antibiotics hormones
and other synthetic chemicals organic
chickens get to live the longest 81 days
compared to intensively reared birds
which live between 35 and 40 days
free-range chickens get the most access
to open air runs but when it comes to
living space organic and free-range fur
far better than intensively reared birds
where as many as 17 adult birds live in
a single square metre organic farming
might offer animals a greater quality of
life but consumers are largely driven by
cost and in an average UK supermarket an
intensively reared chicken cost several
times less than its free-range organic
cousins
you are talking significant cost
difference and I think that's why we've
seen the demand is not there if the
demand was there we'd all be doing it
over 95% of broiler chickens are
intensively rid in the UK organic and
free-range chickens make up the rest to
watch key for me in being a farmer of
chicken is to understand what the
consumer wants to buy we are purely
market driven
for as long as shoppers want cheap and
plentiful chicken they will continue to
be bred ever more intensively
[Music]
you